okay
[Applause]
okay so watching andrew garfield come
back for spider-man no way home was one
of the best moments i've experienced in
a cinema for a long time yeah that might
be because theaters were closed for a
good two years but beyond that the
subtext and meaning behind the scenes
carried much more than it being just a
simple cameo throughout this video i
want to break down why garfield's return
is so iconic and all of the factors that
contributed to what is very much seen as
his rise and fall the entire thing is
pretty much an underdog story but don't
call it a comeback because the guy has
always been excellent we just didn't
know what we had until it was gone now
if you agree then please hit the thumbs
up button and don't forget to subscribe
for videos like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the video
okay so andrew garfield was very much
seen as the black sheep of the
spider-man family toby maguire very much
had one of the best comic book trilogies
of all time and though his third film is
often looked down upon the first two
helped to save the genre in a time when
we were still reeling off batman and
robin maguire was a very big part of
people's childhoods and his first film
especially managed to recapture the
origin story from the comics and updated
in an exciting and modern way sadly his
fourth film was shelled and sony ended
up rebooting the character with andrew
garfield whose first film released just
a mere five years after spider-man 3.
the creative team leaned too heavily
into the great reboot thing which was
fashionable at the time due to the dark
knight but this didn't really fit the
character they also had the difficult
task of telling an origin story that had
already been nailed and though i do
think his first film has aged well over
time when it was initially released it
felt very much like a movie nobody asked
for whilst all this was going on marvel
studios had managed to build the phase
one of their characters and in the same
year that sony launched their film the
avengers pretty much completely changed
the comic book genre fox had also just
released x-men first class the year
before and it just felt like sony were
trying to ride the coattails of everyone
else two years later we got the amazing
spider-man 2 which though enjoyable felt
a bit overstuffed you had the weird
electro story the green goblin one and
peter trying to solve his parents
disappearance which made it just feel
kind of middling it also attempted to
tackle the death of gwen stacy and
though i absolutely loved this in the
film the movie disappointed a lot of
fans at the time however the person
who's shot in the role was andrew
garfield and it felt like he was just
getting the wrong material rather than
actually being bad for me garfield felt
like he was ripped right out of the
ultimate comics and he definitely had
the best costume however he was
competing in a world where we expected
comic book films to all be connected and
at the time maguire was still held up as
the best of the best of the best sir now
sony would you announce the amazing
spider-man 3 at brazil comic-con but
after andrew called him sick the whole
film was scrapped it would be just
another two years until tom holland
appeared as the character in civil war
and garfield was brushed under the rug
as being the person who neither started
anything or had a connected universe
however the internet loves to rally for
those that they think deserve a second
chance and much in the same way that the
snyder cut gained a big following his
version of spider-man did too now
garfield's return got the biggest
reaction when i was in the theater and
though that might not have been the case
in every cinema i think it was probably
the biggest talking point upon leaving
the film there's several reasons for
this and i think one of the big ones is
how it's filmed and revealed in the
scene we watches ned and mj wish that
they could find where peter parker is
and in doing so they opened a doorway to
one of the versions that was brought
across during the spell down a dark and
shadowy alleyway we see somewhat the
silhouette of spider-man and he slowly
jogs towards the camera you can't
slightly make out his suit and on a
first watch this is done deliberately to
make you look at it to see if you
recognize who it is you're kind of
squinting as he runs towards the frame
and then as he jumps through the portal
you recognize the suit and then just as
you have that aha moment he unmasks and
reveals his face garfield even poses and
breathes like it's the end of either an
amazing dance routine or a magic trick
in which the person performing it has
just pulled off the impossible though
many of us knew he was coming back this
moment was still incredible and for as
much as it worked in the context of the
film it also worked really well outside
of it
i just wish we could see peter
now if you visited the internet at any
point in 2021 then you probably saw that
andrew garfield was shown in full
costume onset filming what was clearly
his comeback however he denied being in
the film at every opportunity and it
very much became a meme where he was
constantly saying that he wasn't the
werewolf
i heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
i promise you i am not the werewolf are
we gonna see you toby and tom in the new
movie
i want to get really clear i want this
is this the unequivocal yes no answer i
did not get a call
without seeing the movie nobody could
out now disprove it and we all know deep
fakes are at a point now where it would
be possible to pull something off like
this if you had the time to do it thus
people just kept hammering away at
garfield but he never budged and instead
it just said he was looking forward to
the movie this definitely helped to add
to the oh [ __ ] moment and it's from here
that mj very much becomes the voice of
the audience she can't believe it's
happening to the point that she even
throws bread at him and you're kind of
stuck much like how she is almost
questioning if it's really him we want
to see him be spider-man climb on the
ceiling do something crazy because it's
a scene you can't really believe is
actually happening before your eyes they
could have brought them back in a big
action moment at the statue of liberty
but instead they've toned things down
put it in a home setting and brought
both him and toby back our homes are
very much where we grew up watching the
characters and it's here that we fell in
love with them i used to go around my
grandma's house every saturday and i'd
sit and watch superhero shows while she
made me my sister dinner because of my
memories like this i massively relate
with the setting and it's almost like
they're bringing him back in the place
that i fell in love with spider-man
ned's grandma really adds to the scene
and there's several generations in this
moment showing how spider-man has
touched us all this was so difficult to
pull up for marvel studios and now they
have the cloud to do it there were a lot
of things that they had to do to get the
old cast members back both garfield and
maguire were people who didn't exactly
leave the role on the best of terms but
in kevin foggy we trust the guy managed
to get both garfield and toby maguire
back and have them interact with one
another in very meaningful ways the pair
could have both been reduced to just
being cameos that pop in and leave but
they have quite big parts in the movie
that was very much about the tom holland
version finally stepping into the role
the return of andrew is iconic because
it not only rights the wrongs of the
past in terms of how he left the role
but it also closes several arcs for his
character he was someone who watched the
love of his life die in front of him
because of his own actions and his
version of peter getting to save mj
really means a lot it all expands from
this moment in which he returns and i
love how it all comes together from here
on out andrew's return is iconic and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the scene in the comments below we're
running a competition and giving away
three copies of spider-man noah home on
the 15th of april and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and comment below with
your thoughts on the scene we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now save that to you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out bragdon of all
the easter eggs in spiderman now at home
which will be linked on screen right now
we had some really cool cameos in it
it's one of our best videos ever yet so
definitely go head over there right
after this if not then thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
poor let's see on the next one take care
peace
you